I gotta ask about this big bold decision
at the very beginning to not do
advertisements on the website and uh
just in general the philosophy of the
business model Wikipedia what went
behind that yeah so
um I think most people know this but
we're a charity so in the US uh you know
registered as a charity and uh we don't
have any ads on the site and the vast
majority of the money is from
donations but the vast majority from
small donors so people giving 25 bucks
or whatever if you're listening to this
go donate go donate donate now five
bucks I've donated so many times and we
have you know millions of donors every
year but it's like a small percentage of
people I would say in the early days a
big part of it was aesthetic almost as
much as anything else it was just like I
just think I don't really want ads in
Wikipedia like I just think it would be
there's a lot of reasons why it might
not be good and even back then
um I didn't think as much as I have
since about
a business model can tend to drive you
in a certain place and really thinking
that through in advance is really
important because you might say
yeah we're really really keen on
community control and neutrality
but if we had an Advertising based
business model
probably that would begin to erode even
if I believe in it very strongly
organizations tend to follow the money
in the DNA in the long run and so things
like
I mean it's easy to think about some of
the immediate problems so like if you go
uh to read about
um
I don't know
uh Nissan
car company and if you saw an ad for the
new Nissan at the top of the page you
might be like did they pay for this or
like like do the advertisers have
influence over the content because you
kind of wonder about that for all kinds
of media and that undermines trust
undermines trust right but also things
like
you know we don't have click bait
headlines in Wikipedia you've never seen
you know Wikipedia entries with all this
kind of uh listicles you know sort of
the 10
10 funniest cat pictures number seven
make you cry you know none of that kind
of stuff because there's no incentive no
reason to do that also you know there's
no reason to have an algorithm
to say actually we're going to use our
algorithm to drive you to stay on the
website longer we're going to use the
algorithm to drive you to you know it's
like oh you're reading about
Queen Victoria there's nothing to sell
you when you're reading about Queen
Victoria let's move you on to Las Vegas
because actually they had Revenue around
hotels in Las Vegas is quite good so we
don't have that sort of
there's no incentive for the
organization to go oh let's let's move
people around to things that have better
ad Revenue instead it's just like oh
well what's most interesting to the
community just to make those links so
that um
decision uh just seemed obvious to me
but as I say it was less of a business
decision and more of an aesthetic it's
like oh like this is how I I like
Wikipedia it doesn't have ads don't
really want you know in these early days
like a lot of the ads that was well
before the era of really quality ad
targeting and all that so you get a lot
of banners banners punch the monkey ads
and all that kind of nonsense and so you
know but there was no guarantee there
was no it was not really clear
how could we fund this you know like it
was pretty cheap it still is quite cheap
compared to you know most uh you know we
don't have a hundred thousand employees
and all of that
but would we be able to raise money
through donations and so I remember
the the first time that we did like
really did a a donation campaign
was on a Christmas day uh in 2003 I
think it was there was uh
we had three servers database servers
and two front-end servers and they were
all the same size or whatever and two of
them crashed they broke like I don't
even know remember now like the hard
drive it was like it's Christmas day so
I scrambled on Christmas day to sort of
go onto the database server which
fortunately survived and have it become
a front-end server as well and the site
was really slow and it wasn't working
very well and it was like okay it's time
we need to do a fundraiser and so I was
hoping to raise
um twenty thousand dollars in a month's
time but we raised nearly thirty
thousand within two three weeks time so
that was the first proof point of like
oh like we put a banner up and people
will donate like we just explained we
need the money and people are like
already we were very small back then and
people were like oh yeah like I love
this I want to contribute then over the
years we've become more sophisticated
about the fundraising campaigns and
we've tested a lot of different
messaging and so forth what we used to
think
um you know I remember one year we
really went went heavy with we have a
great Ambitions to you know the the idea
of Wikipedia is a free encyclopedia for
every single person on the planet so
what about the languages of sub-Saharan
Africa so I thought okay we're trying to
raise money we need to talk about that
because it's really important and near
and dear to my heart and just
instinctively knowing nothing about
charity fundraising you see it all
around it's like oh
Charities always mention like the poor
people they're helping so let's talk
about that didn't really work as well
the the pitch that like this is very
vague and very sort of broad but the
pitch that works better than any other
in general is
a fairness pitch of like you use it all
the time you should probably chip in and
most people are like yeah you know what
My Life Would Suck Without Wikipedia I
use it constantly and whatever I should
chip in like it just seems like the
right thing to do and that and there's
many variants on that obviously and
that's really it works and like people
are like oh yeah like Wikipedia I love
Wikipedia and
you know I shouldn't and so sometimes
people say
um
you know ah why are you always begging
for money on the website and you know
it's not that often it's not that much
but it does happen uh they're like why
don't you just get Google and uh
Facebook and Microsoft why don't they
pay for it
and I'm like I don't think that's really
the right answer until it starts to
creep in influence starts to creep in
and questions start to creep in like the
best funding for Wikipedia is the small
donors we also have major donors right
we have high net worth people who donate
but we always are very careful about
that sort of thing to say wow that's
really great and really important but we
can't let that become influence because
that would just be really quite quite
yeah not good for Wikipedia I would love
to know how many times I visited
Wikipedia how much time I've spent on it
because I have a general sense that is
the most useful site I've ever used
competing maybe with Google search yeah
which ultimately Atlanta
yeah yeah yeah but I if I were just
reminded of like hey remember all those
times your life was me better because of
the site yeah I think I would be much
more like yeah why did I waste money on
site XYZ when I could be like I should
be giving a lot of here well um you know
the Guardian newspaper has a similar
model which is they have ads but they
also there's no paywall but they just
encourage people to donate
um and they do that like I've sometimes
seen a banner saying
um oh this is your 134th article you've
read this year would you like to donate
and I think that's I think it's
effective I mean they're testing uh but
also I wonder just for some people if
they just don't feel
like guilty and then think well I
shouldn't bother them so much I don't
know it's a good question I don't know
the answer I guess that's the thing I
could also turn on because that would
make me happy I feel like legitimately
there's some sites and speaks to our
social media discussion
Wikipedia unquestionably makes me feel
better about myself if I spend time on
it like there's some websites where I'm
like if I spend time on Twitter
sometimes I'm like I regret there's uh I
think Elon talks about this minimize a
number of regretted minutes yeah my
number of regretted minutes on Wikipedia
is like zero like I don't remember a
time
uh I've just discovered this uh uh I
started following on Instagram a page
depth of Wikipedia oh yeah there's like
crazy Wikipedia pics there's no
wikipedia page yeah I gave her a media
contributor of the Year award this year
because she's so great yeah Wikipedia is
so fun uh so I yeah so that's that's the
kind of interesting point that I
um I don't even know if there's a
competitor there maybe this sort of
programming stack Overflow type of
websites but everything else there's
always a trade-off there's a big it's
probably because of the ad driven model
because there's an incentive to pull you
into click bait yeah and Wikipedia has
no clickbait yeah it's all about the
quality of the knowledge and the wisdom
and so on no that's right and I I also
like stack overall although I wonder I
wonder what you think of this
I've I so I only program for fun as a
hobby and I don't have enough time to do
it but I do and I'm not very good at it
so therefore I end up on stack Overflow
quite a lot trying to figure out what's
gone wrong and I have really
transitioned to using uh
uh chat gbt yeah much more for that
because I can often find the answer
clearly explained
and it just it works better than sifting
through threads and I kind of feel bad
about that because I do love stack
Overflow and There community I mean I'm
assuming I haven't read anything about
in the news about it I'm assuming they
are keenly aware of this and they're
thinking about how can we sort of use
this chunk of knowledge that we've got
here and provide a new type of interface
where you can query it with a question
and actually get an answer that's based
on the answers that we've had I don't
know I and I think uh stack Overflow
currently
uh has policies against using GPT like
there's a contentious kind of tension
yeah yeah yeah but they're trying to
still figure that out and so we we are
similar in that regard like obviously
all the things we've talked about like
tragedy makes stuff up and it makes up
references so our community has already
put into place some policies about it
but roughly speaking there's always more
Nuance but roughly speaking it's sort of
like you the human are responsible for
what you put into Wikipedia so if you
use chat triputi you you better check it
there's a lot of great use cases of you
know like oh well I'm I'm not a native
speaker of German but I kind of I'm
pretty good I'm not talking about myself
a hypothetical meet it's pretty good and
I kind of just want to run my edit
through chatgpt in German to go
make sure my grammar is okay that's
actually cool